[Musique]
on grandit tout avec ce même rêve celui
de trouver le grand amour auprès d'un
chevalier en armure étincelante et de
vivre heureuse comme dans les contes de
fées le problème c'est que ça n'existe
que dans les contes de fées
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va n'ayez crainte j'ai été
désarçonné plus brutalement et par des
montures plus rapide que votre destrier
d'acier il n'a pas une égratignure mais
apparemment il se prend pour un
chevalier du 14e siècle
messire cole christopher frédéric lion's
de norwich pour vous servir un pur et
c'est entièrement ma faute
d'où est-ce que provient cette mélodie
lyrique de la radio je vais l'aider
jusqu'à ce qu'il retrouve la mémoire
et si le dangereux tu peux me croire il
est inoffensif pour commencer je pense
qu'on devrait mettre à jour votre
garde-robe d'au moins quelques siècles
bonsoir bonsoir je vous laisse vous
habiller
vous savez que le voyage d'un temps ça
n'existe pas n'est ce pas j'ai voyagé
jusqu'ici et il importe peu que je
comprenne de quelle façon
un chevalier se doit d'agir avec courage
et vertus d'apporter son aide à ceux qui
en ont besoin surtout reste où tu es
j'ai bien peur de devoir rentrer chez
moi
tu crois vraiment que rentrer dans son
petit délire améliore la situation
qui sommes-nous pour lui dire qu'il
n'est pas ce qu'il dit être vous êtes
sûr de ne pas être une sorcière et si
cole était vraiment ce qu'il prétend
être
et s'il y avait des choses qui dépassent
notre compréhension
apparemment vous avez tous les deux
besoin de vous faire examiner
on n'est pas obligé parti je n'ai pas le
choix
[Musique]
où que vous soyez je ne veux c'est être
nulle part ailleurs
mais personne ne pas les contre sont des
stars
joli réflexe prenez garde à vous
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci nous suivent
aujourd'hui on avait envie d'aborder
avec les mini de problèmes de boulimie
mais j'ai vingt trois mois elles ont
fait les cent mille abonnés pour 3000
euros est à ce prix là on peut avoir des
commentaires positifs et je le fais pour
une comédie français sur deux serait
qu'au début les gens finiront par
s'intéresser à nous alors aujourd'hui on
avait envie de partager avec vous sur
l'alimentaire parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile de passer au bio quand
on est une famille nombreuse
[ __ ] mais merde vous vouliez paquet
caméra là tout le monde semble qu'orange
de nous c'est chiant d'être allergique
aux chats [ __ ] on aura un chat des
millions dur
[Musique]
j'ai entendu maintes histoires sur ton
espèce ser soler
tu es en mettant le fruit de la magie
un petit parcours le continent
on veut personne de ton ange ans si tu
traque les monstres pour de l'argent
je croyais que tu aurais à des crocs ou
des cornes que sais-je
je les ai lit mais avec soin
toi aussi les gens disent que tuer un
monstre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ne pas qui tu es
cela ferait de moi le monstre que je
suis à leurs yeux chacun de nos choix
nous rapproche de notre destinée
s'il est toujours vivant il reste encore
de l'espoir
je suis à la recherche de girac de ville
juge pas on dit que les sorceleur ne
ressentent aucune émotion quand quoi
quoi tu es le pas
qu'ils soient moindres
suprême
moyen
ils se valent tous
la princesse série là
tapez destinée
je ne peux pas la protéger
si tu fais filles de testage herald
tragédie et cas où se décidera alors
toute l'humanité et ce par ta faute
je prends le risque
[Musique]
ça va vous coûter cher
réfléchissez bien avant de continuer je
prendrai un crédit tout soutien mois
[Musique]
on règle ça ce soir attaque éclair
vous vous rendez compte de ce que vous
êtes en train de faire je crois que je
m'en rends bien compte ou et
c'est pour toi la guerre d'exclusif avec
des droits de visite je vais pas empêché
tomas te voir comment vous vous sentez
au quotidien pour coup mais ça va mieux
tous les deux ça va s'arranger hockey
les ai jamais rien de bien on va bien
votre traitement
ça vous fait du bien oui beaucoup
oui vous en faites pas je m'appelle
claire mois celui-ci qui était petite
fille avec une robe rose
la petite soeur de jérémy et tu sais à
quelle école elle va denton c'est clair
c'est ça bonjour bonjour vous cherchez
une maison c'est quelque chose de bien
se présente donc vous pouvez garder
thomas demain soir serait dû à faire
rien très important vous venez ici
depuis longtemps
environ 10 ans
tatiana gros toi moi elle a l'air plutôt
sympa
vous êtes ami depuis combien de temps on
n'est pas amis les garçons je vous foot
ensemble c'est tout tu ne trouves pas
qu'on se ressemble
si vous voulez je peux prendre les
enfants ce week-end je suis avec papa ce
week-end
j'ai perdu ma petite fille a sept ans
pourquoi vous me racontez ça
parce que plus je regarde le lap que je
suis convaincu que c'est ma fille c'est
du délire
li zhi a été interné pendant presque un
an aucune loi n'interdit de devenir fils
marcel notre famille qui a un peu peur
[Musique]
samantha milieu
ne vous approchez plus de ma famille
[Musique]
faudra me tuer parce que je lâcherai
jamais j'avais perdu la tête
[Musique]
je vais avoir 35 ans est alors 35 ans à
la date de péremption pour une actrice
et le troisième pour le rôle il ya les
belges d'une battante et wii était la
plus forte c'est comme au clic et relève
toujours ton problème est mal ce n'est
pas un manque de talent mais ta
personnalité mais on sait jamais quand
il joue et quand tu joues tu es se dire
oui pour moi c'est un job alimentaire
jeu j'étais quand vous étiez enfin vous
vouliez pas de vendre des frigos non
dites moi une chose qui fonctionne
parfaitement chez vous rien ne sert des
roses à une fleur mortes fleurs mortes
t'as tout compris
il était temps bonjour mais pour le
décès d'un proche
oui mais la personne n'est pas encore
décédé lé en phase terminale passez pas
votre nom qu'il faut remettre cette
bande du défunt oui c'est bien ça j'ai
décidé d'en finir en finir avec quoi
j'ai gâché les dix dernières années de
ma vie alors voilà j'arrête
tu veux plus faire actrice du par
j'avais tant parler je me suis c'était
jour de mon anniversaire
bah si tu as besoin dead c'est
intéressant la peur de souffrir mais qui
n'a pas peur de la mort on était un peu
bizarre mais t'es pas plus déséquilibré
qu'une autre moi je trouve ça
passionnant qu'on ait peu de temps pour
apprendre à se connaître au top
[Musique]
vous savez quand même à quelque chose
dans la tête
[Musique]
tuez-le si vous avez là c'est de leur
igor c'est votre jardinier qui me l'a
donnée vous êtes très aimé
j'essaie simplement d'être moi-même
quand j'essaie d'être moi même les
chants ma pression pour moi j'espère que
cette affaire'' urgente fait pas trop
préoccupante pour vous est-ce que berger
s'enfuient lorsque les loups
apparaissent
notre église prend une direction que je
ne peux plus cautionner du battu pour
accomplir ce qui devait l'être mais j'ai
perdu
l'épave ne renonce pas en renonçant vos
porterait un coup terrible à la papauté
je ne peux plus m'asseoir dans la chaire
de saint pierre vous méprenez fait je
prie dieu est rien jeune je ne peux que
te dire ce rôle il ya un dicton dieu
puis toujours un pape en enfant au monde
son succès sur j'aimerais que ma
punition arrive à la peine pour réformer
il faut être un politicien mais la
qualité primordiale pour un dirigeant
c'est de ne pas vouloir être dirigeant
ce n'est pas moi qui ai besoin d'être
satisfait c'est un milliard deux cents
millions de croyants
l'église a besoin de changement et c'est
vous qui a incarné un possible ça ne
peut pas être moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 est figé dans la nature sans parler de
dieu où puis-je vous trouvez s'il bouge
tout le temps
au cours du voyage nous trouverons
peut-être dieu par là au cours de
voyages je vous le présente
un billet jamais ça n'est pas dieu
nous sommes que des hommes
[Musique]
on ne changera pas le monde en se
conformant aux règles mais le monde doit
changer
qu'est-ce que tu sois prêt à risquer
pour ton idéal à la liberté à la liberté
tes amis
pour l'amour
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
ce cas
si tu arrives en a rien à [ __ ] du
tennis rien à [ __ ] de moi y'a rien qui
t'intéresse d'un tremplin site a la
trouille d'y aller seul on peut sauter
tous les deux
j'ai plus peur de rien ce après adrien
la révolution pour mon paquet couper le
coeur et le lui offrir sur un plateau
qu'est ce qui compte le plus à ses yeux
tes convictions politiques ou ta jolie
petite frimousse tenais pour vivre en
taule
[Musique]
quel risque est ce que tu as osé prendre
pour défendre des convictions un corot
est ce que vos plus avoir la conscience
tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]